the breakdown we've been waiting for
this is the one we've been waiting for
new rock stars
one division episode five easter eggs
and all of them goodies that ea
boss eric voss is working hard at i
wrote down a bunch of possible scenarios
on my own time of like how
how is quicksilver back what is the
purpose of evan peters being here who
brought evan peters here was it one i
got a whole bunch of my own little
speculations that i haven't properly
narrowed down just yet
either way it's new rock stars man erik
voss
welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of one
division episode 5 which
spoilers ahead confuses the crap out of
anyone who still thinks about the fox
x-men movies and scares the crap out of
everyone with
baby vision i hate it after
review watching this episode there are
so many interesting details
hell to break explain what exactly is
going on with evan peters pietro and
sparky agnes
wanda's history with sword so let's go
back through episode five
shot by shot for everything you missed
and we actually got to start before the
episode
because the first comes up in this
previously on segment
where is geraldine she's gone she didn't
belong here
this is actually the third version of
this exchange we've seen the first came
on episode three
oh she left honey she had to rush home
that's right altered point of view from
wanda in episode four
oh she left honey she had to rush home
she still gets [ __ ] changed is being
honest she didn't belong
here even now in episode five wanda's
hex continues to warp reality even
outside the parameters of the episode
itself as it streams on disney plus
the fourth wall i mean breaking down so
much so that
universes are leaking so you may notice
a red
haze glowing off of the glares and light
sources
inside west view this looks like a post
production filter in which all the red
end of the spectrum contained in all
white light was dialed up a bit
just an interesting artistic choice to
show how the scarlet witch's hex over
west view
is becoming a lot of stable i gotta take
a little preview of that again
wow it really is there holy moly he's
all right
what a subtle color correction choices
oh man i thought that's so cool
i would never have caught that witch's
hex over westview is becoming a bit
unstable babies billy and tommy won't
stop crying
why won't you do what i want another
element in west view outside one is
controlling
children and pretty terrifying that
she's trying to use magic to silence
them
something that she might do to say all
mutants
or whatever else she wants to say no
more influencers
charles darwin is the descent of man
which is a title about human evolution
which does reflect the arrival of
mutants to the mcu
and the whole fear they call the x-men
in the comics right replacing lesser
evolved humans
agnes drops by auntie agnes is here and
i've got a couple of tricks up my sleeve
yeah she refers to herself as auntie
perhaps a callback to auntie a's kitty
litter in the supermarket in the episode
two intro which was a clue then that
might point to herbie
agatha harkness who does have a black
cat named ebony in the comics
and a few tricks up your sleeve come on
do you want us to trust you or not
visions distrust throws her off in this
interesting way
jimmy take that again yes agnes is
breaking character and she directs this
to wanda directly as if wanda is the
director of this scene
agnes is clearly not fully under wanda's
control
but she plays the part she defers to
wanda as if she's a kind of partner
in order to earn wanda's trust and it
works vision let's
let's let agnes give it a try good drive
a truck
of course agnes mentions ralph again one
sec
so is he implying that we just haven't
seen
some type of specific interaction
between wanda and
agnes just yet it's a reveal that they
are actually working together on this
obviously agnes is more than just
another person underneath the influence
of
all of this but is the implication wanda
was aware
of agnes this whole time and they've
actually been working together either
that or maybe she had some kind of prior
meeting that has since kind of
faded out of her mind with all the magic
that's happened here
that theory still makes sense even with
the reaction wanda was having to agnes
just because vision was still in the
room and maybe didn't want to give away
you know that it almost could be yeah
like a
break character yeah ralph sprays it on
me every night but there's no tame in
this tiger
now agnes calls herself tiger and notice
throughout this episode there's a toy
yes boys staying in that kitchen maybe
agnes eyes and ears in this house how
she's able to keep tabs on everything
and then the babies go silent they're
empty then where are the twins oh for
just a moment this kind of evokes that
terrifying scene from robert eggers the
witch
where the sister is left babysitting the
baby playing peek-a-boo
until that baby just vanishes because it
was snatched by
the witch look folks parallel to agnes
in the show i'm gonna call it out
billy and tommy just age up five years
and not the way tv shows will kind of
abruptly age up child actors between
seasons to give them new speaking roles
new identities and then agnes says this
oh kids
you can't control them no matter how
hard you try
later vision does observe that despite
westview being for the children
no other children are in westview so
what's going
on other than this i'll just be able to
get one to create these two kids
well i think wanda's hex originally
could only control the minds of adults
in west view because adults are more
likely to have
past pain and trauma that can connect
with wanda's pain and trauma
meanwhile wesley's children are innocent
pure unburdened by life
and thus those children may have been
immune to the hex able to run free now
this diagnosis
manipulating other traumas okay that's
fascinating
family ties with the family portuguese
and the twin theme song
growing pains also has a duet theme song
and the amazing progressing age photos
yeah of course
full house the sitcom that launched the
careers of elizabeth olsen sisters mary
kate and ashley and then that show's
opening featured uh family picnic in the
city
exactly family running and this whole
set is based on the family ties set the
kitchen has the same
kiss the cook sign just like a family
ties
a lone blue cushion which could be not
to that maddening lone blue cushion and
growing paint
and the resting photos of wanda are
actually real photos of elizabeth olsen
but they were edited to place her in
sekhovia
notice these sakovian flags behind her
in the second half how
subtle i assume is the ritziest alley in
sokovia
meanwhile baby vision is a horror show
that i never want to talk about again
why do you say that
this isn't normal billy and tommy
celebrate their birthday with
all five number of candles lit on it
since their rapid agent skipped each of
these birthdays they're celebrating them
all at once now notice how in these
holiday photos vision in costume as a
turkey easter bunny santa each photo
shows him getting progressively
unhappier he clearly no longer wants to
play along with wanda at
i mean in all fairness he's got santa
beard here he you don't really know
smiling you don't really know i'm happy
you don't really know
do you reach it man as monica recalls
being under mind control in west view
there is this one little flash of wanda
sobbing this
looks like a new shot but that
background is westview her clothes look
like the ones she's wearing in that
footage we've seen where she swoops into
that sword facility to take vision's
remains
i'm thinking this could be right after
she brought visions corpse and pieces
to west view to try to resurrect okay
now monica scans interestingly show up
blank
but you can make out the outline of her
neck and shoulders but her body is
coming out overexposed
so monica does have a future as an
avenger she's either going to be named
photon or spectrum
similar powers as captain marvel her
flesh here being composed of pure light
could mean that she already has these
powers maybe the moment want to eject it
damn that's totally free over my head
on each side i've said before that this
could reflect the nine realms
of the cosmos we saw in the thor movies
that middle star hold on a second
oh wait a minute guys they asked to say
like you want to do more blood work and
she's like no i don't want to do that
and i thought that was just because oh
she's you know cool agent who just wants
to get down to business and solve the
problem right away
and then there is that line about uh
captain marvel where there seemed to be
kind of a begrudging hesitant thing that
maybe eric will go into later
but damn that i that completely flew
over my head
it seemed like such a like oh no she
just wants to move on the sword logo
shows up on the table it depicts
nine stars eight on each side with one
in the middle i've said before that this
could reflect the nine realms
of the cosmos we saw in the thor movies
that middle star could be earth aka
midgard now the map also shows this
little label near cape canaveral i'm
thinking that could be where sword hq is
jimmy woo briefs us on wanda's history
born in sokovia in 1989
here we go maxum off both killed during
an air raid when maximoff and her twin
brother tell us what that news station
is
comics were raised by django and maria
max moff but their real parentage is to
be revealed as the children of maggie i
need help
it remains to be seen if the mcu will
embrace this magneto
mckillin might be the one to come in was
described by pietro
and age of ultron remember we're 10
years old having dinner the four of us
and the first shell hits two floors
below it makes a hole in the floor
and many of us believe that is what that
creepy beeping star toaster was
a reference to the mcu in universe news
service whihh returns here and then
hayward cuts off jimmy as he tries to
defend wanda's reputation
i uh try not to speak ill of people then
allow me
to terrorist making it sound like
hayward's a terrorist which he totally
is he was using vision parts to make
sentient weapons subverting visions will
that's why they
had ah that's why they have visions
visions corpse vision is broken up into
pieces
robotics nanotech and a.i projects that
hayward was referring to
guy is a dirt bag further evidence when
monica asks
when was this nine days ago maximoff
stormed our facility
stole the vision's body and resurrected
him
yeah nine days interesting timeline
wanda took vision two weeks after end
game which is about a week before
monica returned to sword hq hayward
didn't tell her about any of this and he
probably knew
exactly what he was sending there to in
westview also you probably yes
exactly weird about it mentioned okay so
really quick
is the implication that they're running
experiments on vision's body
which they weren't supposed to be doing
the details stood a little bit weird to
me that they had vision's body to begin
with they really didn't really much into
it if they were actually doing all these
full-on experimentations with it that's
definitely what it took out i mean yeah
when you look at this photo it's very
clear
yeah and i mean that's such a an easy
way to motivate hayward if he truly is a
villain
already being aware of the reality
that's been created but also
the need for the asset that is vision we
need him back to
continue these experiments and it sounds
like it's probably experiments that they
shouldn't have been running and that's
why it took him so long to brief them
on what actually occurred oh yeah it is
it doesn't go into detail there
in the briefing with you know jimmy wu
and the rest of the sword agents all
them there he doesn't say anything like
we were running experiments on vision
they just said we had vision's body
and i mean if he wasn't happy about the
idea of being resurrected i can't
imagine he would be down with the idea
of being turned into experiments
either billy wears red tommy wears green
which are the colors of wiccan and speed
respectively in the comics it's also the
colors wanda and vision have been
associated with in their wardrobes
sparky the dog is actually synthesized
dog
in the tom king vision series very dark
story here so he was originally zeke the
neighbor's dog the dog who died when he
accidentally dug up the grim reaper's
corpse and then zapped himself on the
site you may remember the grim reaper's
helmet was shown in the floorboards the
episode two animated intro
perhaps in this episode sparky died when
similarly digging up
something in agony
need reference visions newspaper reads
local homemakers innovating recipes
another pointless headline but on the
back an ad for westview appliances
jimmy wu loves getting kind of like a
concept of a vehicle to re-enter west
view and setting her up probably right
down to that
come on it's all in the footage i know
an aerospace engineer who'd be up for
this challenge all right
aerospace engineer is not shown yet it's
just monica texting them a lot of people
are saying this could be reed richards
of the fantastic four
based on hayward's past life i don't
think it is astronauts working for sword
sword very well could be how the mcu
introduces a fantastic four though in
this case i think it would be a bit of
an
understated way to introduce one of the
most highly anticipated marvel heroes
come on descended emails
[Laughter]
yeah we could do it in a text he's
already in one of vision really i think
this engineer is more likely to be the
squirrel daughter of taylor's who monica
befriended at the end of captain marvel
probably one of the extraterrestrial
allies that monaco referred to last
episode maybe someone working with her
hey that'd be a
neat tie-in that'd be a really neat time
spanish subtitles of this they use a
feminine
articles for this engineer so yeah i
think it's all pretty eyes uno player
notice how the id
board
pushes him off
since that witness wouldn't just be
another new jersey resident trapped in
west view that they would put on this
board so this tells me that this
witness is still at large they debate
the events of endgame
uh she could have taken out thanos on
her own if he hadn't initiated a blitz
how'd they get that footage came close
well i'd argue that captain marvel came
close
awkward monica's reaction hints at some
bad blood between her and carol danvers
it reminds me of that interesting
reaction from nick fury well technically
the skrull talos and spider-man far from
home
captain marvel don't invoke her name man
people are hating on carol
they all appear to be on the same pro
scroll side coming out of captain marvel
and that space station fury was on
athena far from home might be part of
sword
so did captain marvel do them dirty did
she betray them did she fail to save
maria rambo and they all hold it against
her
monica's so pissed off that she pulls a
peggy carter in terms of terrible indoor
firearm safety then mrs
seen at work vision awakens norm now
weirdly we did see this written down as
a note on avalash's profile memo
last episode before vision awakened him
and i know you could say time dilation
inside westview but no
it could not have happened until after
monica was ejected from the 70s era in
episode 3
4 to set up this 80's era with vision
and norman yes computer scene
so what's the story here uh continuity
error i just think a lot of these scenes
were
oh really around the same time and out
of chronological order and problems like
this memo were made without the
expectation that
psychopaths like us would be able to
read it ultimately i think this is an
example of them re-editing some episodes
so casual viewers would get more context
earlier but also note that abulash
never says that i just gotta say like
that
that cracks me up because like we we
brought that up in our review but wait a
minute the note was there before
so vision must have done that in the
past and is wanda like
erasing the times of vision's memory
when vision had done this in the past
have they had maybe had this argument
before and then derek just comes and
probably just called it over here i
thought out of anyone
to over dissect it it would have been
eric boss wanda is doing this
just turn the her of this mystery
doesn't have to be wanda
it could be in his head billy train
sparky
sparky sit good dog another sitcom
reference here to the ubu
productions bumper that would play after
the credits of episodes
how billy puts a treat to his temple as
he trains the dog to speak as the future
wiccan he will share his mother's
telepathic
abilities so maybe he's so good dog
training is telepathic and can mind
control animals
then after the attempted drone strike
wanda's pissed she breaches the
perimeter and issues this stern warning
stay out of my home you don't bother me
i won't bother you now you may have
noticed a bit of wanda sakovian accent
making its way back in there she's
reconnecting with the more villainous
roots that she had in asia voltron and
she redirects the sword guns at hayward
though notice
none of them are aimed at monica showing
wanda might still see monica as a
potential ally
it's really just hayward and his
exploitation of visions remains that
pissed off one
so much also turning a bunch of guns
like that
yeah totally a magneto from the first
x-men
and dark phoenix too i'm hoping this big
mystery cameo that the actors keep
teasing it's gonna
this time for lagos brand paper towels
for when you make a mess you didn't mean
to
just like the other commercials we've
seen this is the latest example to echo
wanda's past
trauma when she accidentally threw
crossbones suicide bomb explosion into a
building killing a lot of innocent
people
that was the final straw event that led
to the sokovia accords in the civil war
conflict but listen closely as this
commercial
ends but when you make a mess you didn't
mean to
yeah despite the paper towels this blood
mess
continues to slowly shrip the bloody
mess
wanda made haunting her she didn't mean
to do it
goes missing and the mailman says your
mom won't let him get far
ma'am yeah just like dr nielsen the
mailman is hinting that it is hard to
get too far away from this queen bee
and they find him and it's very sad i
don't know how many leaves he ate i
didn't find him
until it was too late yeah she [ __ ]
killed that dog and they just caught her
trying to bury him
so looping back to that tom king vision
run trigger warning for
animal abuse here virginia beats sparky
the dog to death
and then among the dog's remains
virginia sees that the dog had eaten a
plant
called the wondergore everblood and she
eats another petal
of that and she's able to see the future
as she cries that plant grows
in the yard of agatha parks
yeah i think sparky either dug up or saw
something that he should not have at
agnes property
maybe he's all ralph oh you know there
is something to that because it did seem
kind of odd to me that you would bring
this dog in and just have this big
moment
and i love how this show works all that
in because
to me i'm like oh they're using this dog
death as a way to serve with the subject
at hand
it's a device it's a device they're
using for when
wanda is talking with her kids about
death and bringing them back and then
vision enters to
enhance that subject i didn't even
really read much into the idea of like
oh it was agatha who actually killed the
dog
because of this yeah and then you look
at those tie-ins with the comics i got
eric's pointing here like well now that
seems even more likely
and perhaps with wiccan maybe really
being able to
read the mind of the dog she probably
had to kill
the dog for some specific purpose right
and like the wicked witch of the west
miss gulch
she put a hit on wanda's toto got her
little dog too
because notice how angus reacts when
tommy asks wanda to resurrect sparky
you can do that yeah agnes might feel
threatened that wanda might resurrect
this witness or that billy could use his
telepathic speed command to learn what
agnes was trying to hide from them
or agnes knows full well that wanda can
resurrect the dead
like these two witches already did it
with vision and she's just doing a very
good job playing dumb
wanda pretty hypocritically tells her
kids that she can't reverse death
despite doing a provision
forbidding them to age past 10 which is
interesting where do we land on the
vision things
vision has to bury sparky outside and he
washes his hands this is in the same
sink that he
and we all first saw sparky get in a
bath to be clean and pure enough to join
this family
there's probably a little doggie here
still in that dream wanda tries to use
the credits that's funny
argument here so fun reminded me a lot
of too many cooks
and again all he needs are people who
work for marvel studios jimmy gad works
in post-production
jeremy sister we talked about him before
he's a storyboard artist leanne patrick
post-production brandie hawkins an
extra casting assistant scott mcfeet vfx
team
crawford norman production this takes up
the most time on our new rockstars video
these are all going to come back next
week stacey hudson work some props andra
edwards vfx miriam mccoob works in
production
patrick heskew works on the boxing crush
marvel dialect
coach and he could thank her for want to
sakovian accent coming back you don't
bother me
i won't bother you then after their
fight they are greedy
aaron taylor johnson from age of ultron
but by evan peters
you didn't see that coming the quick
silver from the fox x-men movies
long lost bro get to squeeze his
stinking sister to death or what yeah
peters is really enjoying this he's
playing up the cool uncle like uncle
jesse from full house
yeah mercy darcy's recasting comment
isn't out of the way sitcoms movies will
just do this they'll recast actors
without much explanation
aunt viv rhodey bruce banner and also to
confuse the [ __ ] out of the audience
yeah months ago many of our assumptions
were that it would be some alt universe
quicksilver in that we were looking at a
multiverse crossover now that disney
owns the rights to the x-men
this westview anomaly may be pulling
cultural references from other pop
culture as a way of tying in other
dimensions of the multiverse yeah and
that one of those could just be the fox
x-men franchise
and if that's the logic that's gonna
open the door to a lot of other cameos
from that universe think about it ian
mckellen magneto patrick stewart
professor x
anyone who's in those movies ryan
reynolds deadpool but this could be
something else
could be looking at the mystery force
inside westview jimmy wu's missing
witness with brainwashing capabilities
agnes husband ralph whoever first
trapped wanda in this
that entity could be using a quicksilver
disguise
to try to keep wanda happy when vision
is no longer able to guys i'm not a fan
of that
idea there's something about that i'm
not a
in fan 80s and aaron taylor johnson's
quicksilver wasn't born until 1989 they
just told us
so they needed to pluck a quicksilver
exactly right it was out during the 80s
yeah
first class was in the 1960s days of
future past was in the 1970s x-men
apocalypse was in the 1980s dark phoenix
was in the 1990s and since evan peters
quicksilver was moonwalking in the 80s
in x-men apocalypse he now
does kind of fit in this timeline at
least within the anomaly
now let's not forget he's also in dark
phoenix for five minutes
pietro's return could be something as
simple as a sweet gesture from the boys
trying to cheer up mommy with a
long-lost brother that she said that she
missed but i don't trust this guy he
talks about squeezing his sister to
death he calls vision a popsicle which
feels like a slur the way he says it but
guys guys guys the creepiest detail is
the mirror behind wanda
one second pietro comes in through the
water it's really hard to see but this
mirror looks
distorted warped it almost looks like
pietro's hand
is red and it might be crazy but there's
some weird
blur in this almost as if there's some
thin
grey arm reaching what toward pietro
beckoning him into this house what is
this reflecting
there's nothing there what is that
there's enough in this to see him as a
threat to wanda
some kind of trick to give her the one
more thing
hold on i gotta look back on that that
is
true what the hell is that well i mean
like i'm i'm trying to think like
even though else in this even like a
production design standpoint or
to shoot the scene okay let's move eric
vos from the shot
it would just be wanda and evan peters
who would that be i don't know or
maybe i mean unless it's not like a real
mirror and then you're trying to create
that mirror effect and sometimes you got
to do that in production designs
where it's like oh we got to get like
doubles to be in here because we got a
mirror in the background so we got to
make it look like a mirror and they had
to hold something in place
but it's just a person get this guy in
places
like yeah we can't have any light
bleeding through here so i'm just going
to hold this up and i'm going to frame
right
from the camera angle point there's
nothing crossing in front or behind
evan peters and elizabeth olsen so it
can't just be some production
malfunction i don't know i mean
like if you when you draw in the
skeleton demonic hand it looks like that
yeah but
but at first glance it just kind of
looks like something very odd that is
that is positioning like the pudding
quicksilver there
yeah like beckoning him one there's also
the red hand which people have been
batting around you know
lowering the frame yeah yeah i honestly
especially after hearing
uh seeing eric break down the you know
light bleed turning up the red on all
the white and stuff like that you know
i almost feel like it could maybe just
be a byproduct of that
some kind of trick to give her the way i
got some thoughts
on that but like everything else in west
view it ain't gonna last
ah yes i am wearing our latest obsession
shirt an unusual couple limited supplies
still available at our merch store new
yorkers merch.com
follow me on instagram subscribe to new
rockstars on youtube for breakdowns of
all your one division confusions
thank you eric voss that was brilliant
all right guys look i got a whole bunch
of
theories about how i think quicksilver
what role he'll play
and uh or how he's back kind of want to
narrow it down to just a couple of them
before talking about it in in a video
but i will say that this whole idea of
him actually being like mephisto in
disguise i'm not a fan of that and the
reason why is because we're all
excited about the door this opens up
they're talking about multiverse madness
getting the mutants in here what does
this mean for that future then you just
find out that oh it's just some
it's just some other guy this guy yeah
it's just a disgusting
figure yeah i feel like that'd be a
letdown just think about all the
excitement
this has generated think of what
happened with the whole mandarin thing
you got trevor slattery instead and how
big of an upset that was and i think
that would kind of be a similar thing
after the feelings that this has risen
for the fan community that's the main
reason why i would not want that to be
the case
we did put out a whole video where we
talked or i was i really
i really fought for a while i think
would be professor x who might be that
big level cameo that shows up here
the fact that it is quicksilver it kind
of goes in with some of my theories too
that i feel like well magneto seems
likely now as well
it's all kind of a big mumbo jumbo but
to actually work a tad bit more off of
the point that he was making about how
this version of quicksilver will not be
this
positive case for wanda i firmly believe
that this version of quicksilver
the evan peters one who won't be this
super understanding guy
i think he's gonna be someone who
probably provokes
it's not pietro resurrected it is a
different
pietro it's a different quicksilver it's
the one from the fox universe
i think that even though she got a
pietro back she's not gonna want
him to stick around yeah i could
definitely see some kind of conflict
arising from that i feel like it makes
it
ultimately at least at the outset i'm
sure they can make anything
interesting but it seems more
interesting here to have it be like a
different iteration
of her actual brother because to me that
equates to bigger heavier character
conflict for her
not uh you know one to one but back from
the dead in her
life who she arguably might want to keep
that way and i feel like that especially
in an episode that dives so much into we
can't resurrect the dead and stuff and
we have to deal with certain painful
things you know it seems like this is
almost like a painful thing disguised as
a gift and i feel like that in and of
itself is a great bit of drama
for just his circumstances 100 all right
guys
well new rockstars subscribe if you
haven't done so already another
wonderful breakdown as well hit that
like button subscribe keep a lookout for
more one division videos that we end up
covering last but not least
wanna shout out my man lance door you've
been a great supporter of our channel
for quite some time
but i need to tell you something man
she's forcing you to get married
she's manipulating your mind wake up you
gotta wake up dude
this is not the life you want who i just
said who's to pay attention to the
reference to the show but i guess i just
said she's
the one doing it you can't just go who's
doing it to try to reference the show
you're messing up the improv you got to
listen and react to it
yes and you don't just end all changes
lance i'm sorry i had a whole bit there
and then john just messed it up and
he distracted me with it you taught
emperor how the hell
thank you for being part of the patreon
lance you've been a wonderful guy i love
you i hope you finally get your marriage
fulfilled this year i hope the kid's
okay too
and i hope 2021's better than last year
alright bye
you